that's right it's that time again we're
recalibrating rebooting and hitting
restart on our Infamous anomatron 6000.
the specialized supercomputer we've
developed to simulate improbable
scenarios between the SCP foundation's
various anomalies and any other
characters from any other Universe you
could possibly imagine on today's agenda
what do you think would happen if John
Wick the notorious Hitman highly trained
in all forms of combat was up against an
enemy that won't go down in a single
shot an undead Menace known as
scp-008 well we're about to hit the
button and find out either by a pure
unpredictable instance of human error or
through the act of some Twisted karmic
fate the SCP Foundation had an outbreak
on their hands a sample of the complex
prion a virus known as scp-008 had
leaked the foundation had hoped to keep
the existence of the disease highly
classified even among its own Personnel
Their Fear had been that some hostile
force would attempt to synthesize or
even weaponize as cp008 after all the
disease had a 100 rate of both infection
and lethality it killed anything it came
into contact with or at least it killed
them to begin with before long everyone
in the foundation facility that had been
exposed to the leaking sample of
scp-008's already infected victims was
dead flu-like symptoms were followed
swiftly by a coma however the disease
hijacked the bodies of all those it had
passed to reactivating the motor
functions of their corpses and turning
them into well you can already guess no
one was safe even the mobile task force
on the scene were soon infected with
scp-008 they had been a squad of rookies
and fresh-faced new recruits sent in by
the foundation under the assumption that
an outbreak of this sort should have
been easy to contain it wasn't the
entire facility was soon overrun the
bodies of foundation researcher security
officers and MTF troops reanimated after
their deaths now jostling around in
search of survivors to pass scp-008 onto
that should hold them Dr Alto cleff
yelled locking the entrance to the
Watchtower tight uh this really is
another fine mess claf his colleague Dr
gears replied in frustration our MTF
backup are all down we could be the last
two people on site were locked in a
tower with only one entry tell me what
the hell are we supposed to do now I
will relax clef insisted don't worry
there's someone we can call to get us
out of this jam oh don't say I know a
guy gear side as his fellow researcher
gave a wide grin and reach for his cell
phone a few moments later and only a
matter of miles away another phone
started ringing its owner a man in a
dark all-black tailored suit with a
shadowy shirt and tied to match reached
into his pocket and lifted his cell
phone to his ear good evening I
apologize for calling you at this
came the unmistakable voice of Sharon a
concierge of the New York Continental
Hotel that's quite all right replied the
suited man we received the call asking
for your whereabouts sir a job the man
asked in a monotone voice indeed Sharon
replied up front I'm afraid not the
hotel's receptionist answered
sympathetically the contract is only in
exchange for payment upon completion the
man who made the call was very insistent
he said he would be in no position to
pay until the job is done but he asked
for you specifically and told us he'd be
grateful for your assistance the man on
the end of the line side where oh don't
worry sir the friendly concierge replied
we were sending a car for you at that
precise moment a yellow New York Cab
pulled up to the sidewalk best of luck
Mr wake Sharon said before hanging up
the call straightening his suit the
infamous Hitman John Wick climbed into
the back of the taxi As It sped off
towards its destination arriving at a
complex Upstate far off the Beaten Track
John examined his surroundings while the
car inched closer to the nearest part of
the facility his ears of training as an
assassin under the tutelage of ruskroma
had given him an instinctive spatial
awareness one that came in handy in his
line of work but even then John couldn't
have predicted that something would come
leaping down from above crashing through
the cat's windshield the car's Hood
buckled under the impact fragments of
glass sprang everywhere as an arm
cracked the front window the thing
snarled and gurgled like a wild animal
as it reached for the taxi driver
gripping his arm it pulled him by the
wrist Biting Down causing him to scream
in intense pain meanwhile Jon had
already moved with lightning fast
reflexes and sprung out of the back seat
he hadn't had a chance to assess the
threat his instincts told him his best
option was put some distance between
himself and whatever had just attacked
the car then he'd be able to get a
better idea what he was dealing with the
the job description he'd been hired for
had been light on details John's mystery
employer only referred to it as a quote
cleanup operation sprinting towards the
facility John slammed the door behind
him he pulled off his belt from around
his waist and wrapped it tightly around
the door handles it would hold for now
it was only when he turned around that
he saw a few clustered groups of figures
shuffling around inside the building's
Atrium the nearest Gaggle were close
enough that it was easy for Jon to make
out their pale skin sunken eyes and
cheeks the unnatural twitches and
erratic movements they were making as
the creatures turned to look back at him
zombies John Wick muttered under his
breath that's unexpected the nearby Trio
of scp-008 infecties looked like they
were about to make a dash towards him so
Jon moved fast he raced towards a nearby
Corridor hearing that the three zombies
were already chasing after him their
shambling footsteps had quickly become
an animalistic charge their limbs only
able to move after death thanks to the
virus is that they were infected with
turning a corner John Wick took cover
his shoulder pressed to the wall he drew
his pistol from its holster underneath
his suit jacket and stood in a
battle-ready stance the second he saw
one of the zombies faces appear around
the corner he raised his weapon and
fired swooping around one of his hiding
places to fire another two shots all
three hit Center Mass right through
their chests the noise would no doubt
have drawn the attention of the other
scp-008s in the building but for now the
three that had been on his tail dropped
to the floor only to start getting back
up again Jon wasn't used to his Target
standing to their feet after hidari
fired at them and the nearest of the
zombies staggered back to his level he
lifted his firearm again before his
finger could compress enough force on
the trigger though the undead
Abomination took a wild flailing swipe
at him the scp-008 instance knocked the
weapon out of John's hand causing it to
clander to the ground while it reared
back its other arm for a second strike
catching the blow John Wick displayed
his incredible reflexes and Mastery of
martial arts he delivered a series of
precise punches and chops deploying a
combination of Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
Aikido and Krav Maga to try and knock
the snarling monster down with each hit
he was careful to avoid the zombie's
mouth having seen one bite to the cab
driver earlier Jon had assessed that
scp-008 could be transmitted through
biting and he was correct exposure to
mucous membranes or bodily fluids of an
infected individual was what allowed the
virus to spread one of the other scp-008
zombies that were still in the process
of climbing back up swipe Jon's legs out
from underneath him the master assassin
toppled over landing on his back with
the weight of the first Monster still on
top of him while the second Claude of
this tapered suit pants seconds before
it could snap its teeth down on his
ankle Jon pulled back his leg and shot
it back out in a devastating bicycle
kick that sent the second zombie reeling
into the third which was still trying to
get back up after its earlier gunshot
but the first of the creatures were
still bearing down on him mustering as
much of his Peak Physical strength as he
needed John Wick held the zombie at Bay
blocking it with one arm stopping it
from getting close enough to bite him
his eyes started around looking for
something anything he could use that was
one of Jon's most enviable and
impressive skills one that made him so
renowned as a legend of the Assassin
world in the hands of John Wick any
ordinary everyday object could be a
Lethal Weapon reaching out with this
other hand Jon felt his fingertips brush
against something metal who was so close
just Out Of Reach on top of him the
zombie flailed its arms trying to clod
him lifting both legs in a fluid
balletic motion John Wick kicked the
creature off of him crawling towards the
nearby object and grabbing it just as
the zombie started to approach again
with the swing and a loud metallic clang
the heavy fire extinguisher collided
with the SCP 2008 infectious had the
force of the blow caused it to drop in
an instant Landing in a heap on the
floor John waited a second to see if it
would get back up again but it was still
the other two zombies suddenly dashed
towards the infamous Hitman only for
their prey to duck and weave
effortlessly between their aggressive
clawing swipes bashing his makeshift
weapon against their heads like a
battering ram against a door all three
were down but the entire facility was
still crawling with a mass of the
reanimated monstrosities calmly John
smoothed his suit and straightened up
his shirt and tie walking with the fire
extinguisher in hand back down the
corridor towards the sound of more
scp-008 zombies snarling they were next
the Baba Yaga would use anything he
found to take down each and every one of
them until not one was left standing it
didn't matter if all he had was a fire
extinguisher or one of the Fallen
security officers batons or even just a
tiny pencil nothing would make it out of
that facility alive he just had to go
for the head still trapped in the
Watchtower Dr clef and Dr gears had long
since grown irritated with each other's
company they had no security feeds no
way of knowing what was going on within
the overrun Foundation facility for a
while the pair of researchers had been
toying with the idea of climbing out of
a window and scaling down the side of
the tower but giving up on that plan
when they'd realized they'd only be
dropping back into a horde of scp-008
zombies a sudden explosion erupted from
one corner of the complex causing gears
and cleft to direct their attention
towards it from their elevation they
could see the ground below was littered
with the bodies of the scp-008 infecties
rendered lifeless once again by
significant cranial trauma in short
something had been bashing the zombies
in the head or someone the sound of a
banging against the locked Watchtower
door startled both Foundation scientists
instantly they thought that the zombies
had made their way up the steps and
found the two researchers easy prey
trapped in a cage the heavy thud against
the metal door repeated then there was a
pause deafening tense silence filling
the room a polite knock came from the
other side of the Watchtower entrance
cautiously clef approached to a market
standing in the doorway as it opened was
a single figure panting with exhaustion
but still nowhere near Beaton he looked
out at cleff and gears from his dark
hair a Stern expression on his face
neither one of the researchers could
believe that he was still alive still
uninfected but then again he was the one
and only John Wick the Baba Yaga now go
check out Boba Fett vs scp-610 the flesh
that hates and
scp-076-abel vs chainsaw man who has the
most lethal weapon for more epic out of
universe what-ifs